martin biron hélène buzzati christian
dufour bonsoir bonsoir vaccin vaccin
vaccin que c'est un sujet d'accord qui
nous importe tous pour des raisons
évidentes depuis que j'ai vu il ya trois
semaines maintenant ce reportage de
s'exciter minutes à cbs où on a
interviewé le grand patron le général à
la retraite qui allait gérer cette
opération de distribution du vaccin
je me posais la question ne t'ont on a
préparé un tableau pour vous qui va être
en charge pas si ça que les gens se
demandent qui va organiser ça bon mettez
vos lunettes
au canada c'est le général le major
général cadieux qui est en charge de
l'opération vaccins en notariaux série
qu'ils aient lieu général ancien chef
d'état-major du canada l'ontario l'a
engagé comme étant le grand responsable
distribution aux états unis
je vous en parlais donc si le général en
retraite super nanas qui avait à coeur
qui est reconnu pour sont ses talents
d'organisateur pur août bien au québec
j'en a mis un point d'interrogation
parce que pour l'instant c'est un sou
mines et jérôme gagnon qui est à la tête
de ce alors martin ma question est
est-ce qu'on va pas mettre général ou
six au québec où quelqu'un qui est
habitué des grandes opérations parce que
distribuer des millions et des millions
de doses
ça va être délicat oui on va nommer
effectivement quelqu'un qui va être en
charge je serai franchement très
surprise que ce soit un militaire je
pense que la solution votre plus
nationaliste avec ce gouvernement de
françois legault
il ya différentes solutions on va
probablement nommer quelqu'un qui
connaît le
le calcul cette expérience-là de ces
deux vaccinations massives jeux soumis
comme ça le nom d'alain poirier le
docteur qui a été responsable de la
santé publique à la place du docteur
horacio arruda
en 2009 lors de la vaccination de lahej
h1n1 alors lui il a une expertise est ce
que ce sera lui
peut-être pas mais ces quelques comme ça
qu'on va aller chercher pour organiser
cette vaccination alors ça ça risque
d'être ça va être vraiment content que
rock quelqu'un de nommer dites vous ça
sera pas le swing est ce que j'ai montré
non et elle aime buzzati parce qu au
canada et en ontario le violon tally
voir l' expertise des grands militaire
parce que c'est des opérations complexes
les militaires ont cette expertise oui
parce que c'est d'abord une opération
logistique que vous l'avez dit faut
distribuer c'est d'autant plus chaque
personne doit recevoir deux doses
combinés à ceux que vous avez deux des
trois vaccins qui sont les plus
prometteurs qui doivent être gardés dans
des réfrigérateurs très froid fait des
congélateurs moins 80 dans un cas au
moins 20 dans l'autre il faut avoir les
infrastructures pour entreposer ses
millions de doses là je sais que le
gouvernement fédéral a déjà acquis 126
ha oui c'est ça semble un petit
congélateur pour garder ce bac c'est
l'homme et donc c'est extrêmement
compliqué une chose par exemple que je
voudrais mentionner c'est que on ne le
sait pas encore exactement comment se
fera la distribution des doses entre les
différentes provinces
il ya des négociations en cours entre
ottawa et les provinces devraient
peut-être dire çà et là non parce que
j'ai peut-être dans mon art balma pour
l'organisation et c'est que le fédéral
va laisser aux provinces
l'organisation de la distribution mais
le fédéral reste le maître d'oeuvre de
la distribution des vaccins mais de la
répartition preuves et réparation de
savoir voilà savoir quelle province
or combien de vaccins et ensuite chaque
province selon ce qu'on comprend pas ce
qu'on ne peut pas encore beaucoup de
tôles détail chaque province ensuite
décidera de son ordre de priorité qui
risque d'ailleurs d'être pas mal sous
l'ère d'un endroit à l'autre
je constate que l'ontario
depuis quelques jours maintenant un
scoop toujours vote à voir si je puis
dire en révélant le nombre de doses
qu'elle s'attend à recevoir 2.4 millions
du 6 mars et ottawa ne veut jamais
confirmé ces chiffres là que je
comprends c'est qu'on est encore un égo
et peut-être quotas que l'ontario essaye
de placer un peu ottawa devant le fait
accompli en divulguant les chiffres
chaque fois qu'ils sont circulées le
pigeon un gars qui connaît
l'organisation a cru qu'un lieu qu'à la
tête de sa crise tient ça fait du bien
de parler des vaccins oui troisième
vaccin en dix jours qui semble efficace
puis on nous dit que ça pourrait aller
clairement plus rapidement que prévu
en ce qui a trait là dessus nous sommes
du vaccin j'avoue que on a souvent fait
une analogie entre la lutte conte en
pandémie une guerre pour moi j'avoue que
j'ai tendance à faire confiance aux
militaires là dedans je trouve ça
dommage que ce qu'au québec on n'est pas
des militaires qui est bien en vie a
dégénéré mais mais je trouve que les
visiteurs respirent confiance sont
formés pour 50 cc exactement
d'efficacité et j'espère que ça me
rassure moi qu'on aille chercher des
gens qui étaient au plus haut niveau qui
ont fait leurs preuves
j'espère qu'au québec que martin je vous
dis un jour donné à parole après que ça
je les olé j'ai monté le sujet me
stimule beaucoup le lancer général
laroche qui étale en afghanistan dirigé
les troupes est allé ensuite à
l'atteinte de la sécurité civile du
québec puis vous savez pendant les
inondations elle est en charge des des
troubles dont ça s'est déjà vu la wii
moi aussi j'ai pensé brigadier
c'est parce qu'ils savaient fini mais
juste pour revenir sur la question de
l'armée au québec et je pense que le
gouvernement legault veut pas manquer
son coup avec la campagne de vaccination
alors ils vont aller chercher la
meilleure personne peut effectivement
j'avais pensé au brigadier général
laroche qui a quand même qui est assez
connue au québec
bon là personnel il faut choisir bon la
question de faire affaire avec l'armée
bon aussi que le gouvernement de
monsieur le goût dû se pincer n'est là
pour faire appel à l'armée dans les 6 h
et celle dés lors de la première bagarre
ils ont rompu peut-être pas là mais ils
veulent pas manqué leur coup et
s'assurer que ça se passe très bien
oui c'est déjà la retraite toute façon
évidemment demande pas l'armée mais ce
serait des gens elle retraites et sur ma
peau laroche madonna plaindre il ya
plein de généreux il ya sept générale
qui devait aller en irak la belle est
encore en exercice et louis christian à
l'isi je suis assez d'accord avec tout
ce qu'on dirait l'année martin a conclu
régis en zinc le gouvernement du québec
a vraiment pas droit à l'erreur dans la
distribution du vaccin parce que il
beaucoup de ces derniers mois le dr
racine bureaucratique et politiques
locaux et justesse il faut là les
vaccins sont lol
au québec on s'organise qu'on nomme les
gens qui sont bons mais qu'on s'organise
qu'elle soit distribuée est efficace
trois militaires paritaire qui soit que
mon âme dans tous les cas de figure une
ou un général pour pas c'est une
opération extrêmement complexe
puis il ya de l'info gain de
l'informatique derrière tout ça et qui
en vaccinant premier aussi c'est ça
martine la santé publique coup ci doit
arriver avec un plein bien sûr mais
c'est si ce qui est en train de se faire
actuellement l'offre parliez du
sous-ministre gagnon il fait partie de
ce comité là et c'est ce qu'on est en
train de regarder sur comment on va le
faire est ce qu'on va le faire par
exemple en milieu urbain en preniez en
région après où on va faire tout le
monde en même temps c'est sûr que
différentes étapes et ce sera la semaine
des vaccins et le monsieur legault va
faire un point de presse demain on va en
parler de la question des vaccins
pourraient conduire un peu plus loin sur
ce que c'est le comité mais aussi des
discussions et là n'en parlait
coûts de négociation avec le
gouvernement fédéral ça se passe entre
monsieur legault et trudeauiste parle
assez régulièrement sur cette question
là et mais la mise en oeuvre la
vaccination là sur le terrain c'est le
québec ces provinces du bon sens et on
ad extra tabac aujourd'hui c'est relié à
ça mais c'est plus globale les
conservateurs poser des questions on va
écouler sans voir venir
et voila voila pas le thriller
administration américaine nous demandent
un plan d'opération la chaux et fed
avancent le plein de tribus sion et
commencer sous six ans avant parlons les
plus petits pays les pays bas les pays
bas ont annoncé que la distribution se
révèle l'éjection serait fait aux gens
de 60 ans et plus aux gens qui ont des
problèmes de santé et aux travailleurs
de santé première ligne pourquoi le
gouvernement ne fait pas de plan global
pikine allonge pro kadhafi pour avoir
une distribution des vaccins
la chose la plus important c'est
d'acheter les vaccins et c'est pour
cette raison que je veux souligner que
le canada a fait ça et c'était important
de rassurer les canadiens
et d'expliquer qu on a vraiment le
meilleur portefeuille d'achat de vaccins
au monde sa la question revient hélène
beaucoup les gens me posent la question
pour nous j'ai créé est ce que c'est
vrai qu'on a le meilleur portefeuille on
a fait les bons choix dans les candidats
vaccins pic on aura assez de vaccins au
canada en tout cas à date ces trois en
trois les trois qui ont annoncé leurs
candidats on en a et si on fait le
calcul des doses on arrive quasiment au
même quantité suffisante pour vacciner
la totalité de la population alors à
date le moi je suis pas un expert mais à
date on semble avoir misé sur les bons
chevaux
je pense qu'il est un peu malhonnête de
dire le conservateur le disais dans
l'extrait que y'a rien qui se fait la
gueule beaucoup de travail en amont qui
s'est effectuée sur la distribution du
vaccin
ottawa trois planches là-dessus à temps
plein c'est simplement que on ne veut
pas pour des raisons de fin de
négociation on ne veut pas tout de suite
mentionné où on en est rendu mais le
travail est bien avancée et et c'est à
peu près certain que les employés du
secteur de la santé seront les premiers
à se faire vacciner à recevoir les
premières doses
est ce que le fédéral va exiger un ordre
de distribution province ou pour le
choix de qui le recevra bon ça semble
une évidence les gens qui travaillent en
première ligne mais au delà de
l'évidente après ça qu'on élargit le
cercle on va où tutu et après il ya
plein de possibilités
il ne semble pas y avoir de directives
d'ottawa et je pense que si on regarde
tout ce que fait monsieur trudeau et son
commandant magique à présent qu'ils
étaient plus à l'aise attention ne pas
avoir l'air de dicter aux provinces
comment faire des choses qui relèvent de
leur domaine qui m'étonnerait beaucoup
qu'il aille dans cette direction là on
est des images de rosemère samedi vous
c'est peut-être sur les réseaux sociaux
mesdames et messieurs des gens là qui
sont venus faire une petite
démonstration en enlevant leurs masques
et en dansant dans le centre commercial
il on peut voir ça s'il vous plaît et
les il est alors on fait quoi on fait
quoi devant saint martin
bon la police en voyant une
contravention mais sinon tant pis pour
eux s'ils volaient tenons donc quoi cc
c'est un peu le son de cloche que moi
j'entends au gouvernement par l'un d'eux
ne nous c'est un peu seul il ya d'autres
termes qui ont aidé au d'autres
qualificatifs que de nous mais ça
ressemble pas mal à ça ils sont mis à
l'amande et ils seront mises à la mangue
ça continue mais on remarque quand même
que c'est une minorité particulière
honnêtement c'est pas nécessaire d'aller
danser dans un centre commercial sont
les contre portes du mas mais enfin
alors oui seront mises à demander
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui les policiers ont
émis pas loin d'une vingtaine de
contraventions dont et ça vous savez ça
christian est bon et ça c'est vraiment
qu'ils des manifestes sont rendus loin
dans la réflexion
il ya tous les autres plus caché qui
trouve ça difficile bien sûr
voilà la frustration monte ses terres qu
il faut faire appliquer la loi je trouve
qu'ils ont déjà
on applique la loi sans état d'âme mais
faut pas se cacher tu fais que vivement
le vaccin parce qu'on ne peut pas
continuer comme ça indéfiniment les gens
m'ont viré foule
il ya vraiment une frustration qui monte
à beaucoup de niveaux cette semaine dans
la presse un texte très très fort
d'un jeune étudiant félix d'erreurs mais
on a des excuses moi qui pose vraiment
des questions fondamentales la donne
quand il excusé moi quand il me disait
par exemple c'est vrai sommes nous
confiner pour en une excellent je vais
vous lire je voulais comme sont les
repas de chaud mon quotidien se résume
ainsi écran marche dodo la soupape qui
aidé ma santé mentale
je ne l'est plus je ne peux plus voir
mes amis je ne peux plus à l'université
je ne peux plus m'impliquer en
présentiel écrit-il
et finalement j'aimerais que vous
considériez monsieur le premier ministre
la possibilité de nous consulter nous
les jeunes avant de prendre des
décisions
parce que nous on fait quand nous vivons
avec ses blessures c'est sûr que mon cas
que peut faire monsieur legault mais c
est ce qu est ce qui est intéressant
c'est le cri du coeur derrière ses
effectifs oui mais mais mais parce que
je trouve qu'il va plus loin il sort en
tout respect il pose les bonnes
questions et aussi il donne ses réponses
à lui quand il dit ça nous confiner pour
nous protéger du virus pour pour
protéger notre système de santé
c'est une des questions qui est
fondamental ce qui est quasiment
philosophie quand ils sont trop ministre
écoutez il ya des conséquences est ce
que vous faites on a besoin d exutoire
et les nomme les exutoires
il parle en fait des restaurants des
théâtres et salles de sport des débats
ils demandent pourquoi cosco alba que
les états sont ouverts alors que ces
histoires ne sont pas ouverts et je
trouve que c'est un jeune rappelons que
les jeunes c'est pas eux qui sont les
produits menacés par l'aco vieux la
santé mentale raté le sait c'est aussi
important que la santé physique
moi j'espère que le vaccin va arriver au
plus tôt parce que si la crise devait se
prolonger des mois et des mois
je trouve qu'il va falloir donc on
change des choses parce que je vais pas
dijon movie répondent oui et imposer
quand même des bonnes questions puis lui
aussi martin sur le le cosco d'un côté
puis 101 visé que cosco les grandes
surfaces d'un côté les jam et les
théâtres de l'ontt jamais du monde à
l'échos quoi en fin de semaine
mailly ce type de lettre l'autre que ça
interpelle particulièrement le
gouvernement puis monsieur legault l'a
déjà dit dans plusieurs points de presse
que s'est trouvé ça difficile pour les
jeunes qu'il fallait trouver des avenues
de solutions et et pour donner des cours
en classe souvient on est en train de
regarder à différentes solutions qu'on
aimerait appliquée mettre en place pour
l'hiver ce qu'on était pas de le mettre
partout 6 po clair on regarde son peu
près pas par exemple utiliser des salles
de dans des hôtels des salles dans des
centres de congrès pour que les cours ou
collégial se donne en personne parce que
ça devient extrêmement difficile pour
ces jeunes là qui sont rivés à leur
écran là je me donne les parents qui
doivent un peu capoté de voir leurs
enfants dans leur sous-sol qui sont
seulement un lien avec leur écran à
seuil
il ya des choses qui veut que le
gouvernement veut mettre en place
mais s'il l'est et la machine reste
lente et l'ancienne et qu'il aimait loeb
jeu s'entend délais mais son équilibre
du ses notes
même si monsieur turdu n'a pas à gérer
lui avec chaque réglementation son
équilibre difficile
oui et en fait philosophiquement je
ferai un lien entre ce cri du coeur et
cette manifestation dont on parlait un
peu plus tôt je ne veux absolument pas
endosser cette manifestation qui s'est
fait à l'intérieur et donkey eux c'est
encore une chose que ces manifestants ne
veulent prendre des risques mais ils ont
exposé d'autres personnes qui ne
voulaient pas taillé pas à des risques
inutiles mans mais cette manifestation
est trahi le fait qu'il ya un point de
vue que jamais vraiment été entendu dans
ce taux de cette pandémie c'est qu'il ya
des gens qui pensent qu'on aurait dû
laisser passer la maladie protéger les
personnes les plus vulnérables dont les
personnes âgées et pour le reste
assumer ce qui est encore pire découle
sans imposer toutes ces mesures
extrêmement difficile économiquement et
sur le plan de la santé mentale
ce point de vue là n'a jamais vraiment
eu droit de cité et c'est ce qui fait je
pense que certaines personnes se
radicalise et on arrive à faire un strip
tease d'un masque dans un camp de dachau
bon c'est malheureux n'a pas le temps
j'aurais c'hlas et là dessus parce qu'on
a quand même parlé puis christian rue
d'etion on va reparler
c'est un rendez vous donc à vous trois
merci beaucoup
à voir soirée merci